for years star wars fans have dreamed of
seeing some of the sagas many cancelled
projects from the underworld tv series
to george lucas's sequel trilogy would
they be just as excited for a droid
spin-off for an ewok video game though
we'll let you decide
james mangold's boba fett movie could be
the greatest last the star wars fandom
will ever suffer the celebrated director
and academy award nominated writer was
the man who delivered the suburb final
chapter in wolverine's cinematic story
with logan and there can be no doubt
that he would have brought a fantastic
boba fett story to the screen mangold
proved with both logan and 310 to uma
that he can make modern westerns with
equal parts brutal action and thematic
heft while the mandalorian has certainly
offered fans a more western inspired
taste of the star wars universe a
feature would have allowed mangold to
flesh out a more epic story this movie
might even have been the film that
brought the franchise back into the best
screenplay category at the oscars given
mangold's previous historic nomination
for logan of course there's no way to
know for sure but that doesn't make this
particular last any less painful
a wookie focused movie was an idea that
george lucas came up with when initially
developing star wars somewhat
disastrously this idea eventually led to
the star wars holiday special
but with the right script and a creative
director this could be something far
superior to that particular outing
lucas's original idea was a film that
didn't focus on chewbacca but instead
allowed for a more ethnographic study of
wookies no one knows exactly what the
story would have been but the wookie
homeworld of kashyyyk has a significant
history of occupations and uprisings
that would lend itself perfectly to a
wookiee focus story the movie would
likely dive into their culture while
also offering the classic rebels versus
oppressor storyline that's such a staple
of the star wars saga and based on the
battle on kashyyyk in revenge of the
sith it probably would have looked great
too of course you've got to consider the
fact that wookie's only speaking
unintelligible grouse while this may
seem like a problem it's also an
opportunity for something really
exciting and somewhat avant-garde a lack
of spoken dialogue has driven some
fascinating movies such as 2014's the
tribe in which the characters only speak
in ukrainian sign language doing
something similar with the wookies could
have been a huge success or a terrible
failure but it would have been
fascinating either way
a droid only movie was another concept
for a one-off film that lucas had in the
70s one that also could have developed
into something truly special for the
franchise the obvious reference point
for this kind of thing is wally which
proves that you can tell a story that
focused on robots and still be engaging
and emotionally impactful the major
differences of course are that lucas
envisioned a movie with no human
characters at all as well as the fact
that many droids can speak in languages
that viewers can understand while the
film would not have made room for any
human characters it would have allowed
for comprehensible dialogue between the
droids like the wookie focused movie the
idea here was not to extend the stories
of droids that viewers knew already but
to tell an entirely separate story that
explored how droids interact with one
another when other life forms aren't
around considering audiences have only
been given glimpse of this kind of thing
in existing films it's likely that many
fans would have clamored at the chance
to see a little more
star wars underworld was a live-action
tv series that was going to take fans
into the murky depths of the star wars
universe the show promised to be a more
adult take on the saga offering up fresh
and exciting stories that weren't solely
focused on the skywalker clan it would
have taken place between the end of
revenge of the sith and the beginning of
a new hope and explored the dark
underbelly of coruscant you want to buy
some death sticks you don't want to sell
me death sticks i don't want to sell you
death sticks you want to go home and
rethink your life i want to go home and
rethink my life the idea this time
however was to offer something much more
morally ambiguous and narratively
complex than the films themselves a
small screen format and long-form
structure of television storytelling
would have allowed for more dialogue and
character-driven stories the creator's
ambitions for the show were impressive
too with frequent lucas collaborator
rick mccallum telling sfx magazine the
shows we aspire to are the sopranos the
wire battlestar galactica deadwood all
of that group while disney has now moved
star wars into the world of prestige tv
with the mandalorian that show still
feels pretty pg when compared with the
shows mccallum mentioned for now we can
hope that the fact that the mandalorians
runaway success might be a source of
hope for underworld's future
george lucas says sequal trilogy would
have been very different from the one
disney ended up producing as revealed by
lucas in interviews for the book the
star wars archives arguably the most
exciting aspect of his trilogy ideas
were the villains lucas's big bads would
have been darth maul and his new
apprentice the tweedlek darth talon in
these movies maul's power would not have
been governmental but instead criminal
lucas envisioned a power vacuum after
the fall of the empire that would have
been filled by more he would have united
the criminal world and became the
godfather of crime in the universe the
films also would have placed leia at the
heart of the story working to combat
maul's influence on the galaxy and
rebuild the republic meanwhile luke
would have been attempting to rebuild
the jedi order from the remaining jedi
who survived order 66 finding him on a
mission to locate potential jedi
throughout the galaxy saga would then
reveal that it's actually leia who was
the chosen one as she is the one who
brings harmony to the galaxy through the
creation of a true republic it's almost
certain we'll never get to see these
stories play out now that we already
have a sequel trilogy but with dc and
the mcu both opening multiverses what's
to stop star wars from joining the fun
thanks to the announcement that
lucasfilm games are remaking the 2003
classic rpg knights of the old republic
there have been rumors abound regarding
the long-lasting knights of the old
republic 3. sadly nothing is yet
concrete and there's no way to know what
the game might look like given that it's
been more than 15 years since the last
installment but according to chris
avalon lead designer and writer on
knights of the old republic 2 there was
always an idea for a third game
according to him the story would have
focused on an ancient and even more evil
group of sith of course this won't come
as a surprise to fans of the old
republic games considering the second
installment teases a hidden cabal of
true sith on more than one occasion
certainly one of the most exciting
aspects of the third game will be
unraveling the mysteries of these hugely
powerful beings each of whom has to be
given a unique origin story sadly no one
can even be sure whether these ideas
will be a part of knights of the old
republic 3 even if it does one day
appear but that won't stop fans from
dreaming
star wars 1313 seems like it would have
been the video game equivalent of
underworld with the game even apparently
aiming for an m rating players would
have controlled boba fett as he
traversed the 13th 13th level of
coruscant and unravelled a massive
conspiracy like underworld the game
would have been more adult-oriented by
virtue of its brutal violence as well as
a more complex character-oriented story
like the cancelled boba fett movie the
game would also have been the first in
its medium to focus solely on the
legendary bounty hunter as opposed to
the many games in which he takes a more
sidelined role but unlike the movie
which many thought would be more of a
western story 1313 was to be an urban
crime story something resembling film
noir and mafia stories more than any
western at this point however it seems
that nobody will ever see this game in
any form which is certainly a real loss
to the franchise
an animated comedy developed by the
creators of robot chicken star wars
detours actually has 39 completed
episodes apparently though it didn't
quite fit with what disney had in mind
for the franchise when they bought it
that might seem surprising given the
huge success of the star wars robot
chicken sketches among fans clearly
george lucas was willing to let people
make jokes about his beloved franchise
and the fans would have loved it too
considering the trailer makes it clear
that the show is stuffed with all kinds
of references easter eggs and clever
jokes
r2
nobody's talking to you trash can
it also seems as though detours would
have been a great way to give more
screen time to characters who only
appear briefly in the movies such as
dexter jetstar who based on the trailer
seems to have been a main character on
the show while co-creator seth green has
said that there isn't any interest in
releasing the show anymore fans can
still hope that detours will eventually
see the light of day
do it for dexter disney star wars return
of the jedi ewok adventure was one of
two video games developed for release
alongside return of the jedi for some
reason though only its sibling death
star battle ever made its way to ataris
of course ewok adventure wouldn't be
developed for the atari today but the
idea of playing an entire game as an
ewok is undeniably appealing whether the
concept is retooled for something
grander or stays as little more than a
mobile game for example it's pretty easy
to imagine this concept being retored
into something like little big planet
giving players a tool to create maps
that include a variety of traps and
contraptions like those that ewoks
create in return of the jedi this could
also bring a community aspect to the
game that would allow players to share
their creations and fight together
against the invading empire
alternatively it's very easy to imagine
that the original game would be given a
fresher look or remaining little more
than a time sync mobile game either way
everyone loves ewoks and the video game
centering endor's vicious little teddy
bears would surely put smiles on a lot
of faces
battle of the sith lords was a star wars
video game that would have allowed
players to take on the role of a young
darth maul as he grows into a more
powerful sith lord albeit not entirely
of his own volition in fact the game
would have delved into how traumatizing
the training of a young sith lord can be
with maul being kidnapped by palpatine
as a child and tortured into taking on
the role of his apprentice sadly the
development of the game ran into
timeline and law issues with the
franchise's plans to bring more back as
a significant character in the clone
wars animated tv show once that happens
the game development team was left with
too little information to work from
while also being logged into new
canonical facts about maul's life
eventually after significant development
and a number of shifts in the game's
trajectory the game was cancelled this
isn't only a shame because the game
would have further developed the story
of a beloved character though that is
also true but it's also a last because
battle of the seth lords could have been
one of the franchise's most significant
moves into the realm of horror with a
key aspect of the game being the way
that maul used his own fear to
manipulate the fears of others sounds
pretty cool don't you think
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]